alex schreibt einfach wir kennen alle
ich habe auch dem klub und dann hatte
ich ein kleines buch welches geld dazu
kommen zu einem neuen werke ich hier mit
laptop mit andré und das heißt wir
machen heute wie der zuschauer stories
leute lange nicht mehr gesehene form
aber ihr habt eine seiner fleißigen 2000
einsendungen der in dortmund
dementsprechend leute schauen wir heute
doch einfach mal was die jugend von
heute zu tage was ihr so erlebt was eure
wirklichen lebens geschichten sind und
verstaatlichen zu begegnen die erste
schicht willkommen von lohra er schreibt
zwar in der ersten klasse und selbst da
bist du ein ornatelli ihren und weiter
mit kumpels halt mal auf dem klo oder
war alles schneller als ich dort und in
wahrheit nur die einige kläger einzige
toilette habe mich hinsetzen verträgen
habe ich im stehen geflügel- und weil
der körper stoff war habe ich einfach
neben des clubs ich dachte mir nichts
dabei arbeitete danach muss die vielen
neben dem klo putzen seiner familie mein
ich war in dem moment meine lehrerin mit
in dem zeitpunkt wo wir müssen auf jeden
fall mal prüfen was in dem verlust ist
heute das macht die lehrerin auf die
männer führung da konnte er einfach
neben das tor ist tor geschlossen so
einige eine menschliche reaktion so
latour verstopft denn war es nur ein
bisschen diana leute wieder raus wenn
ich meine die berner auch nicht wenn du
vier stunden auf dem platz in der den
clubs oft ist dann bist du ernster
nehmen
du machst das so nicht gefragt wenn es
klubs stoff ist desto eher nehmen dazu
bewegte geschichte hallo mein name ist
ja ich habe mal geguckt
ich meine es gibt objektiv mein cousin
mein thema sie kommen hat gesagt guckst
du diesen scheiß schon wieder das muss
ich mir wirklich nicht bieten lassen und
in die nächste geschichte ist auch
richtig hartes von java oder richtig
politischen geschichte thyrow maschinen
wir hatten einen hübschen eltern dann in
der schule den preis kann die trainerin
ute bock mehr kranke mal eine
mathestunde macht modernen einzige kante
hat er immer nicht angenommen 30 fragen
wie nötig denn die klammern auf und
hatte nico mendt nicht angenommen da
vorne gegangen und hab die klaren als
objektive besitzt jeder kern weggewischt
er werde dafür geschichten wirklich
nicht wie du in der schule in die leber
achtende verliebt will nach vorne und
planes den übeltäter mäßig in höheren
klassen weg bist ok geschichte richtig
heftig den kopf von einer mutter
tatsächlich meine mama geschichte ein
stück und folgt wahrscheinlich eine
etwas andere geschichte
die eignet er sich vor zwei jahren bei
der geburt meines sohnes war damals 19
jahre alten schule kannte nach dem
krankenhaus und verdienen sie morgen ist
wichtig schmerzen nicht mehr ertragen
schrieb förmlich nach merkte auch die
netze waren aber verweigerte und meinte
etwa jedoch nicht so schön daraufhin
bekannt so eine wut auf die da sind
einfach an fliegen und anschließend
ihren arsch bewegen sollte wenn es
fertig denn es ging ein gutes licht
wechsel war nicht allein über bekamen
die wir auf dem posten werden motive
sage immer wer weiß ich wenn ich die
erste hier zeigt er auf den kreis
getroffen
soziale werdende mutter mit einem kind
im bauch im bett und schreit machen wir
lieber gesagt nee du bist kein youtube
und hat eine erwachsene person die alles
gibt's doch gar nicht die nächste
geschichte ist auch richtig geil die
kommen vom team jugendarbeit auch eine
sehr feine die geschichte wir sind im
was in der schule die kopfhörer
handwaschbecken gefallen wir
rausgegangen hat mir wieder musik
angemacht habe aber nichts gehört
ich hab immer wieder auf volle
lautstärke gedreht und nur ein kleines
bisschen gehört alle angeguckt habe ich
dann gemerkt
meine kopfhörer nicht ein der toilette
so die klappen da rein so kopf drinnen
war sodann mit der pop-gruppe volle klar
auch wenn die und schwierigen moment
stehen vor der klasse einfach die auch
so passieren könnte bei dir in der
nachbarschaft zu erschweren
meine nachbarin 84 mit einer unterhose
auf die fahrt gegangen und wird dabei
eine schubkarre egal wie oft ist das
tier wird wenn das jetzt auch schon
passiert ist dann lass doch mal ein
leichter
48 mal von mir allein dreimal der
letzten woche ja ja der installation wie
weit kann ich die gegen flughafen
immerhin unterhosen
[Gelächter]
niemand geringerem als alex meine leute
möchten von euch jetzt ist sie zu hause
auch einfach mal meldet wenn euch die
geschichte so oft passiert ist an der
küste schreibt einfach bekennt alle ich
habe auf dem klo geschickt und dann
hatte ich einen penis bruch erkenntnis
es immer wieder so oft in letzter zeit
ja du kannst du mal geschichte wie ihr
bestimmt auch e mails gibt aber zu hause
weg auch kennt egal ob die mädels ja
aber alle die möchten nicht so einfach
sagen 'bitte dinge einschicken die
arabischen besonders wenn man wenn mir
das alleinige woche verlieren wollen wir
eine minute länger da gibt es einfach
brauchst du hast mit der mängelliste
spricht weil es gibt so ein sammelkonto
boulevard feste zusagen wie von alexei
also ein tägliches anwendung wie hier
von congo after gmail.com vor der zeiten
die geschichte für meinen neuen serie
formularen bringt ja es läuft ich habe
euch kennengelernt
lukas tabellenbild aufgaben
[Musik]
ich gebe einfach mehr betrifft ist bei
den dkb dkm mal einfach eine
professionelle business in der konkreten
geschäftlichen anfrage kometen grüßen
und verabschiedung
ja leute ganz normaler tag wieder ich
muss sagen die einstellung waren heute
wieder sehr notdürftig sehr viele
alltagssituationen nervige einbindung
auch noch von lukas parkhäuser
schlechter tag heute auf jeden fall
werde ich warum bekomme ich natürlich
vorschlagen das video hier abonnieren
und hier oben gibt manchmal multimedia
könnt ihr gerne hättest du schon mal